good morning my name is Eric Saltzman
I'm a founder and board member of
Creative Commons and I'm going to talk a
little bit about Creative Commons and
more about some of the issues we're all
been dealing with this couple of days
and my background that seems so it's all
converging here I'm a cab ride to the
airport to get here I was in cab with a
Haitian driver who's telling me about
his son and how proud he was that he's
in engineers guy just arrived here about
15 years ago with his kids with a 91 is
an engineer in bioengineering and he
guessed immediately that I was a lawyer
and I sort of said well I used to be a
lawyer he said no your lawyer always a
lawyer and so I haven't made films for a
long time but if I've always been a
lawyer and can't deny that one that I
also now want to say that I was a
filmmaker and possibly couldn't find
enough red tape in the legal world so
moved to the world of media and that's
what we've been talking about for the
last few days in the nineteen late in
nineteen eighty I made a film about a
legal case and that was a hybrid in a
way of the type of hybrid we may want to
talk about some more here because it
started out that the project was funded
to make teaching films for loss goals
and then I learned to do that and
ultimately made that this documentary
film before that I was an AV operator in
junior high school
I had a pin to Davy I really remember
very well the filmstrips I remember one
of the movies perfectly well somebody's
talking about how important this is or
how we learn from these habitats I
remember one and drivers that call dead
right everybody seems to remember and I
being an AV operator I also did it wrong
and i put the 16-millimeter film in and
didn't have the tensions right on the
bell & howell projector and I snapped
the thing and I have to splice it back
together and using the splicing machine
I cut off a bit of the tip of my fingers
I was afraid to tell the AV guy as I so
wanted to keep my ad days I went to the
nurse and I told her if you couldn't
tell me but um so this has been
importantly for many years this film was
made in nineteen eighty and now as you
can see i kept the rights to it was
shown an ABC they had the rights to a
play or two and now it's up on a thing
called common content which somehow vets
or collects open content material and
when when i say open content we'll get
to some more definition of that
on march nine nineteen seventy eight
this man Jack Jones 51 years old and
unemployed shot and seriously wounded
another man in the decaying hotel in
downtown Seattle I 707 scary and the man
shown shot Brendan Collins also known as
big man is in critical condition at a
local hospital
Jones is charged with assault with
intent to commit murder if that'll be LJ
equivalence Evans too so to put this in
perspective this was the first long
format tape news of project at ABC had
and a year later I made something for
EDT and you saw how crude these graphics
were what we had access to a hard disk
in a big room all by itself with some
cooling device and we had we got 10
minutes to use it that week was a hard
disk it's probably even on some tiny
fraction of what we all have now on our
computers well does anybody need to know
about how creative commons works or put
it this way are there people here who
are not very familiar with how creative
commons works because it's been talked
about a lot there are some okay so I'm
going to take liberty it's about this is
about a two and a half minute flash
video and it explains how creative
commons work so i'm not going to talk
about creative commons too long but i
think it's it's a worth understanding
these are Jack and meg white also known
as the white stripes they're a band from
Detroit they make rock and roll without
a bass guitarist this is steve mcdonald
of the veteran band Red Cross Steve
thought the White Stripes could use a
bass player so we appointed himself he
took the White Stripes latest album
called white blood cells and re-recorded
it laying a base track down on every
song then he released the results as
mp3s on Red Cross's website he even made
up a new album cover entitled red blood
cells McDonald began putting these
copyrighted songs online without
permission from the white stripes or
their record label during the project he
bumped into Jack White who gave him
spoken assent to continue it can be that
easy when you skip the intermediaries a
collaboration across space and time
creative co-authorship with people
you've never met standing on the
shoulders of your peers it's what the
internet is all about it can be that
easy when you skip the intermediaries
but couldn't it be easier still not many
of us are liable just to bump into Jack
White and get the green light and he's
not going to let just anyone play the
bass over his songs in any case but what
about other artists who might want you
or me to play along shouldn't we be able
to if they don't mind enter one of the
Internet's most famous citizens a face
for me to the world over a public
identity rivaled only by a handful of
corporate giants and global superstars
the big copyright c everyone knows what
Big C stands for Big C means all rights
reserved Big C means ask permission Big
C protects copyright owners and notifies
the rest of us of their ownership time
was when you had to put Big C on
he wanted to copyright or else it
entered the public domain the commons of
information where nothing is owned and
all is permitted you had to put the
world on notice to warn them that was
big C's job and it was a useful one what
changed the law by the late 1980s US law
had changed so that works become
copyrighted automatically the moment
they're made the moment you hit save on
that research paper the second the
shutter snaps closed the instant you
lift your pin from that cocktail napkin
doodle your creation is copyrighted but
the Big C makes a cameo or not so
suddenly there's no quick way of knowing
whether something's owned or not the new
rules may be clear about how you get to
own work you don't have to do anything
but they say nothing at all about how
you should go about announcing that you
want to allow certain uses of your work
so what well if you're a digital
filmmaker whose every frame must be
cleared by an army of lawyers before
making the cut what if you're in a band
whose label won't let you put a song on
a file-sharing Network or if you're a
professor trying to put together online
course materials or if you're a DJ
chasing down permission to use every
snippet of song in your sonic collage if
you're one of these people then you know
so what we interrupt this brainstorm to
call the lawyers you drop what you're
doing and call all the lawyers you ask
for permission even to use a word whose
author doesn't mind if you use it
because you have no idea what the
author's intent is you asked for
permission even to share some of your
rights boy you venture forward unsure
what your risks and rights are exactly
or in a haze of legal doubt you do
nothing the bottom line Big C is out of
a job the middlemen are not
enter Creative Commons Creative Commons
wanted to find an easy way to help
people tell the world up front that they
want to allow some uses of their work we
call the experts the US Copyright Office
for advice their response there's no
real answer get creative so we got
creative how our CC brand marks works
that are governed by Creative Commons
licenses a set of standardized copyright
licenses available free of charge on our
website we wrote these licenses so that
lawyers and courts could read them then
we translated them into the language you
can read and then we translated them
into a language computers to read now CC
isn't meant to compete with copyright
but to complement it it allows you to
retain your copyright while granting the
world permission to make certain uses of
it upon certain conditions if the Big C
is like a red light then CC is a green
light if the Big C says no trespassing
the CC says please come in if the Big C
says all rights reserved CC says some
rights reserved so you can use the
powers of the net to find works free to
share and build upon and to invite other
people to transform or trade yours so
that you can get creative not only with
what you make how you make it available
so you can collaborate across space in
time so you can be a co-author with
someone you've never met so you can
stand on the shoulders of European
all without asking permission because
permission has already been granted
Creative Commons get creative it's easy
when you skip the intermediate okay so
you get the idea there are various
licenses that one can choose from and
the stripes are basically you can choose
a nun all licenses now require
attribution to the Creator you can
choose a non-commercial license you can
choose a license that allows it doesn't
allow derivative works and a few other
stripes okay now as has been clear the
last few days all this is really easy if
you've created all the work yourself if
you're an individual or you've got a
team and everybody agrees that what
you're going to do is going to be put
under a license of this sort we like
creative commons licenses because we
know by now that they work the system
works metadata attaches to them people
can search for them there are various
ways to search for work under very time
so the system works well but what people
have been mainly talking about the last
few days of something or the last day
it's something more complicated and that
more complicated thing is what happens
when you want to take material from
various sources some material that main
organization be legacy material and
allow it to the use so we've been
talking about some different
organizations I want to bring this one
up even though we're being hosted by
Columbia here's an attempt or an effort
that Columbia did some years local favim
and Fallon here's fathoms website now I
guess it's still up there it's so
material up there but when fathom got
started it was a meant to be of a profit
Center for Columbia University and
Columbia's partners and Columbia looks
like put in Columbia shut down in 2003
it's for-profit online learning designed
to sell web-based courses and seminars
to the public they even had at Columbia
at the time an office that was meant to
support professors in building these
sources and the professors were going to
share in the profits and in 2001
Columbia gave having 14 point nine
million dollars while aventurine seven
thousand dollars from fees and then
after where they shut it down so we we
are past that model there are of course
some private universities and gaged an
online learning for a fee but the big
public institutions and the small ones
are not doing this anymore mit we've
heard a big discussion but open for a
story mit is a really early example NMIT
goes and makes sure they they have an
operation that clears rights they they
get they only work with professors who
want to then and then they clear the
rights and they use a Creative Commons
license which you can probably see and
at the bottom here here's the Creative
Commons license some rights reserved on
the right and the license that Creative
Commons uses is it what I but it's going
to be
okay okay so but anyhow it's it's one of
the licenses and under the following
conditions you must give attribution
it's non-commercial and you must share
alike so that much that means you may
make derivative works MIT this is sort
of a little inside baseball MIT oh okay
what why was he the only one to warn me
why didn't the rest of you see that yeah
put my links mit has done something that
they put under their faq s they've got a
license that says noncommercial share
alike so derivative works are permitted
and they have put onto their faq s
nevertheless that this is meant to be
for educational use i'm going to show
you that in a minute we'll get there
that adds up I went and looked at the
wall previous speaker was talking and
went and looked at the open courseware
consortium and what the open courseware
consortium says is that they want people
to use the licenses in fact they require
I guess people to use licenses that
permit derivative works so MIT does that
the discussion we saw from the people at
Columbia yesterday looks like that's a
closed tool kit that doesn't allow works
outside Columbia has made the choice at
least for now that what they're doing is
presenting you with a tool kit if I
understand that right you can play
whoever you are
time university within that toolkit is
that right yeah you have to log in but
that toolkit is closed so what we're now
talking about are the various stripes of
openness yeah we're not forcing people
to love remix that is in our agreement
that it's required but there's some sort
of don't have that culture today so
we're allowing something to come in
depending on the values are a little bit
of different call but we're sort of
nurturing them with a strong
recommendation right okay so you're
you're aiming to get there and now
you're urging people to do it and most
do all right we don't want people to be
scared away if they're not there yet
right Creative Commons is about to
launch a new a new initiative we have
now Creative Commons has a sister or a
sister or daughter organization called
science Commons and now we're about to
launch with generous help from hewlett
foundation an organization that what we
call learning commons or CC learn and i
want to we spent time writing this so i
want to read it too soon so you can hear
it here's what the learning commons is
going to do and you'll see what the
learning commons is going to do is to
try to coordinate on the technical side
on the legal side and even on the
networking side the world of open
educational resources learning commons
will focus on removing barriers to
sharing and reuse of open educational
resources some barriers are legal some
open resources are licensed under widely
varying terms with conditions that
restrictive hard to understand are
mutually incompatible with those of
other oer sites there are technical
barriers between oer sites designed our
own individual ease of use without due
regard for enabling the finding
combining and localizing Patera
other open sources worldwide and there
are cultural barriers that include the
absence of a network orientation toward
oh we are so one of the things that I've
come away with in these day in have so
far is that there is not yet an
understanding of how open educational
resources will network together we saw
at Yale they're going to be open and
allow derivative works some others don't
but the way in which these systems will
talk to each other the way one can
search across platforms is not yet well
worked out and the Creative Commons
hopes to bring its expertise to that
area
you